new study finds a link between newer
forms of hormonal birth control and the
risk of breast cancer it found a small
but meaningful increase in risk
following the extended use of birth
control pills
IUDs and other forms of hormonal
contraception before this study the risk
was mostly associated with older forms
of birth control that had higher hormone
levels dr. David agus joins us to
explain why the news is a surprise to
many doctors dr. agus thank you for
joining us from California this morning
so details first please and what
concerns you most good morning Gail the
you know this is one point eight well
million women in Denmark we're all on
one health system so we can look at
their electronic records and in these
women there were significantly higher
cases of breast cancer in the ones who
are on oral contraceptives and
intrauterine devices that are hormones
well this is the first study that it's
shown intrauterine devices with hormones
having association with breast cancer in
large numbers and obviously with the
lower dose of oral contraceptives we
thought there wouldn't be as much of a
risk as the higher dose but it turns out
to be the same about a 20% increase in
breast cancer overall 9% if you're on it
for a year and up to 38 percent if
you're on it for 10 years or more
we know that studies have long
established that exposure of breast
tissue to female hormones is what causes
breast cancer so that's an established
link so what's the effect of the study
should women stop taking birth control
no with any drug or anything you take
there's a risk and there's a benefit and
you have to look at that I mean this is
in absolute terms a relatively small
risk a hundred thousand women on oral
contraceptives or this intrauterine
devices sixty-eight breast cancers a
year if you're not on it it's 55 so it's
a small increase so you have to have a
discussion with your doctor based on
your family history and based on other
factors to decide
remember oral contraceptives also lower
the risk of ovarian and endometrial
cancer so there is a balancing act here
does the age of the women matter no
question about it and so obviously
younger women a you know on oral
contraceptives and as you get older and
you're on it for longer the risk seems
to go up so women over 35 should have a
serious talk with their doctor about
what
they should still be on these oral
contraceptives and this is still in
evolution so it's gonna be a discussion
between you and your doctor dr. David
agus thank you so much we appreciate it
thank you